gonna level with you guys I'm gonna keep
it real here I wear hearing aids in both
ears not exactly street legal keep that
on the DL that doesn't mean anything
I do wear hearing aid but I don't want
any pity no sympathy I love my hearing
aids in fact you guys should be jealous
cuz I take my hearing aids out to sleep
I sleep like a baby oh man I don't hear
a thing I wake up feeling so refreshed
it's amazing it really makes you wonder
who has the disability it does it really
does no it's me I have to disability
since I take my hearing aids out to
sleep I don't use the same alarm clock
you guys use I use a vibrating alarm
clock I put it under my pillow and it
vibrates so powerfully it's amazing it's
a lifesaver I love it but it's also
terrifying so scary because all my
dreams end in an earthquake and my
hearing aids aren't waterproof which is
ridiculous so I have to take them out
when I'm taking a shower or when I go
swimming so you know pool parties are a
nightmare I'm not very good at the game
Marco Polo that's not my game now the
whole lot of polo happening when I'm
playing that game lots of Marco
when I first started doing comedy I
didn't even want to do any jokes about
my hearing aids I didn't want to be the
hearing aid guy you know I was I was
watching this interview it's a really
famous comedian and he talked about how
he became famous for doing a certain
type of joke and when he tried to do
other stuff people didn't want to hear
it because they pigeonhole him and as
soon as I heard that I was like you know
what I'm not doing any jokes about my
hearing aids
ain't nobody putting this guy in a box
that's what I said and I meant it and
then a couple minutes later in the same
interview he talked about how he made 20
million dollars last year that changed
my perspective quite a bit I remember
when I heard that part I screamed so
loud my hearing aids broke because I
wear hearing aids I have a disability
I'm the hearing aid guy I assume you
guys are laughing I can hear I'm really
dad anyways guys I wear hearing aids and
come on not $20,000,000 you kidding me
I'm not leaving that kind of money on
the table honestly for 20 million I'd go
for Helen Keller
I'm after that Helen Keller money baby
oh man could you imagine faux Helen
Keller 20 mil oh man I'd buy myself a
yacht
I'd be out on the open water just taking
in all the beautiful smells me and me
and my partner broke up recently and got
really quiet in here or did it no I
heard that I know why it got quiet it
got quiet because I said partner right
and as soon as that as soon as somebody
says partner and you don't know them
well you can't even focus on the rest of
the conversation you're just trying to
solve the mystery huh I don't care
either way man I just need to know
you're all looking at me trying to crack
the case right now we've kind of got
that list but that could be the
hearing-impaired
[Applause]
now me and my girlfriend broke up to
clear up that mystery because I realized
I was gay
you